now this is a baptist ministers uh
admission Dr ET T hiscox author of the
Baptist manual that there was and is a
command to keep holy the Sabbath day but
that Sabbath day was not Sunday it will
however be readily said and with some
show of Triumph that the Sabbath was
transferred from the 7eventh to the
first day of the week thank God for him
being honest with all his duties
Privileges and sanctions earnestly
Desiring information on this subject
which I have studied for many years I
ask where can the of such a transaction
be found he says not in the New
Testament absolutely not there is no
scriptural evidence of the change of the
Sabbath institution from the 7th to the
first day of the week and then he just
comes right out with it of course I
quite well know that Sunday did come
into use in early Christian history as a
religious day as we learn from Christian
fathers and other sources but what a
Pity that it comes branded with the mark
of paganism and Christian with the name
of the son God then adopted and
Sanctified by the papal apostasy and
bequeathed as a sacred Legacy to
protestantism and that's why they can
say that you may read the Bible from
Genesis the Revelation the Catholic
church and misss and you will not find a
single line authorizing the
sanctification of Sunday and looking at
this this is a medallion from the Roman
Empire so when John the Revelator heard
was heard the number 666 I believe he
knew it was tied to this number and the
numbers of the zodiac 1- 36 you put it
together it adds up to
666 in ancient
[Music]
paganism many people in this country
have fought and died for your ability to
worship freely what you feel you need to
worship and uh so we're going to discuss
this very important topic of this end
time worship on the table uh God is not
a forceful God and uh we're starting to
see the inklings of worship being talked
about as a necessity which it will
ultimately move more into a you need to
do this or there will be trouble so
today we've got an awesome guest Dr o
he's been on our show before maybe
you've seen uh the piece that he did
with us the Black Panther that was an
awesome piece oh yes it was but welcome
to the show he's a pastor and uh this is
a passionate topic on your heart and so
I'm excited to have you here aboard
Ellie
and uh let us let us dive into this
where are we going with this uh we're
just going to go right where Jesus wants
us to go so the people of God can hide
in him um prophecy is not meant to scare
but to prepare and as the Bible says he
that dwelleth in the secret place of the
most high shall abide under the shadow
of the almighty and that's what we want
to do abide under the shadow of the
almighty and allow Christ through his
Revelation to reveal to us what is to
come so we can stay away from the evil
one you know God has never done anything
major or major events happen on the
earth that he didn't tell people what
was going on so it would be
uncharacteristic like him if you read
the Bible some major event like the end
of the world's coming about and he
doesn't let people know what's going on
right so I I'm excited to get into this
Bible study and and and see where this
is going because I feel like and I don't
know about you guys do you feel like
prophecy is being fulfilled in front of
your eyeballs absolutely I mean stuff
we've read about for you know when we
were kids or you know our parents
reading about or even their parents are
reading about and it's like we're in the
generation that this is actually
happening in front of us yes so I'm
excited for this we're living in
exciting times and I've been a 7-Day
Adventist for um over 30 years and the
things that I've been reading when I was
a teenager I'm now seeing comeing the p
and I Pray by the grace of God that I'll
be alive to witness it and to lead
Millions to Jesus Through the anointing
of the holy spirit amen and I like how
you said like look this is not to scare
anybody this is to just help help us
understand the times that we're living
in and to be prepared we don't want to
be caught off guard so we kind of know
we need to know what's coming down the
pipe we we don't and you know when we
talk about prophecy we have to talk
about the God of Prophecy right and it's
in Revelation chapter 1 before we talk
about Beast we got to talk about the
lamb and his name is Jesus in The Book
of Revelation CH 1 and verse one the
Bible gives us and I like to start off
with this because this is very pivotal
the Bible calls it the revelation of
Jesus Christ so we shouldn't be scared
of the one who loves us which God gave
unto him meaning that God sees all
things from the the end from the
beginning which God gave unto him to
show unto his servants the things which
must shortly come to pass the Bible
makes it very plain in verse three that
blessed is he that readeth so we're
supposed to read about these prophecies
and then the Bible says hear the words
of these prophecies you can you can read
it but you got to hear it too but the
Bible says and keep those things which
are written therein for the time is at
hand what you want to say about that you
know a lot of our audience um may not
have a context of Daniel or Revelation
they may not even read it um I know a
lot of churches actually discourage
their church members from reading this
book don't open it you're not going to
understand it and um I believe that that
this book is for our day and age it's
it's it's written for us to understand
what's going on right now and um so I
hope if any of you guys out there
watching this um you've never opened
this up before I I hope this is an
inspiring conversation to you that you
will actually just listen just listen
and ask God to open your eyes during
this whole conversation all right and so
what we want to do is you know this is
really highlighted in the message of the
Everlasting gospel which Jesus says must
go throughout the whole world as a
witness the thing is the Bible says uh
the Bible teaches the principle this is
about worship this is about who you're
going to worship and how so the Bible
says uh that we should Worship the Lord
thy God and him only shalt thou serve
but in the Everlasting Gospel of
Revelation 14 the Bible tells us to fear
God that's the first thing he says and
give glory to him and worship him why
because Satan is setting a counterfeit
Kingdom through the beast power and
that's what this update is all about and
I want to just go to a couple of slides
here um the main thing is as we look on
the slides here you know knowing who the
M who the major players are in
Revelation 13 we have two beasts the
first Beast symbolic of the papal power
the second beast symbolic of the United
States apostate protestantism in the
United States which will enforce the
worship of this first beast and with
this in mind the Bible talks about
something that's coming down the
pipeline the Bible says and he had power
to give life unto the image of the Beast
that the image of the Beast should both
speak and cause it as many as would not
worship the image of the Beast should be
killed the Bible talks about this second
beast power which many prophecy Scholars
have correctly interpreted has America
so this country has a pivotal part to
play in Bible prophecy now that's a
beast that that um it it it it looks
like a lamb but speaks like a beast
right speaks like the dragon I speaks
like speaks like the dragon so it's
basically it's it's having the same like
methods as the devil basically but in
the Garb of a Christian lamb and it's
interesting because the Bible says
Behold the Lamb of God which taketh away
the sin of the world so Christ is a lamb
so this beast power which Bible prophecy
symbolic of a kingdom professes to be a
Christian Nation outwardly but through
it speaking through his laws it reveals
the spirit of the Dragon which the Bible
in Revelation 12:9 describes as the
devil so Draconian measures will come in
a Christian country that will have
worldwide influence to lead people to
worship this beast power God is always a
a god of free will I mean that's why
we're in this message to begin with
right it's because he's allowing us to
have free will and anytime you see the
Free Will being trampled upon or taken
away that is not God's Kingdom right
it's it's not God's kingdom and we see
that in Daniel 3 when worship was
enforced by law worship was enforced by
secular laws which called for a death
penalty that is not the way that Christ
would have it the Bible says that Jesus
has come to save men's lives not to
destroy them but these beasts will come
together to seek to destroy and compel
men to work worship the dragon
Revelation 13:4 talks about how the
whole world would worship the dragon
which gives power un the Beast and the
focal point of this revolves around the
day of worship in this next slide here
uh we have two things we have the Seal
of the Living God um symbolic of God's
sign his Mark of authority which is the
Sabbath which points to Christ as the
Creator but we have What's called the
mark of the beast which we see here is
Sunday why um beast power the papal
power in this uh slide here the papal
power tell tells us that Sunday is our
Mark of authority and so what happens is
is that the mark of God has been
replaced with another Mark with a
counterfeit day of worship and just kind
of kind of put some um some historical
ex Jesus to this the number 666 in my
studies derives from the worship of the
son in the ancient Roman Empire which
was worshiped on the day which we call
Sunday meaning that legislative I want
to make sure I'm clear legisla Sunday
worship will be not is presently but
will be the mark of the beast which of
course as Bible scholars have shown will
come when we have what's called a
national Sunday law and want to put a
disclaimer out here because we don't
want people think because they worship
on people worship on Sunday they have
the mark that no one has yet received
the mark of the beast because the
testing time is not come there will be a
test when there will be a de decree when
no man will be able to by our s and one
last thing before we go to questions is
is that the receive the mark of the
beast is a diabolical attack on God's
law because the Bible teaches a
principle in James that if we break one
commandment how how many have we broken
we broke them all brw so what happens is
in the mark of the beast crisis to
receive the mark of the beast would
entitle the breaking of at least the
first four Commandments as you look on
the screen here if you worship the beast
in His image as the Bible tells us not
to you will violate the first and second
commandment but if if you receive the
mark of the beast and the name of the
Beast you violate the last the the next
two so we so see how this issue revolves
around worship and thank God our God is
so wise to give us these 10 principles
that outline um um God's of God's
relation to us and our relation to him
as well as to each other just I just
wanted to point out that um you know one
of the original things that Satan was
fighting for in heaven was worship he
wanted the worship right so it makes
sense to me that in Full Circle it's
like his his initial reason he started
in this war in the first place comes to
Ultimate fruition and he's requiring now
forcing people to worship him and so I I
I think that's why um some people you
know they get it they get it wrong at
like that the mark of the beast is this
or that or getting a tattoo or you know
it's like they can name everything under
the Sun but it really does deal with
worship you started this off so
beautifully and you painted a nice
picture when when it comes to verses and
the intentionality of the Bible how it's
written let's say the fourth Commandment
remember the Sabbath day God said that
because he knew that certain people
would forget um and in the context of
Revelation starting out there is a lot
of fear surrounding it right and it's
it's so beautiful that the first few
verses in Revelation is a encouragement
of no read understand why so you won't
be afraid so you have the knowledge
therefore you will not perish um but why
do you think you're speaking with a lot
of confidence and authority and
understanding someone who this is new or
maybe they have that faar they've never
opened the book why is it that
Revelation is so filled with symbolism
with beasts and all this was there any
intentionality behind that well the
Bible is a composite hole and God could
have just told us in playing black and
white but he wants us to use our our
thinking powers in the beginning when
the beasts were brought before Adam he
could have told him what the name of it
was but he wanted Adam to use judgment
and to compare things together to give
it a name so God gives us these symbols
and he helps us out with other
scriptural references so we can put it
together and the beautiful thing is on
this side of the Old Testament living in
the end of time we can see how these
prophecies has been fulfilled from
Daniel 2 from the golden image the Beast
of Daniel 7 where we see Babylon metor
Persia Greece and Rome which has been
universally accepted by Christianity as
the four powers so we can trust Bible
prophecy and as we continue to go
further we see further Enlightenment and
God promises that there will be a
blessing he gives us a blessing of
understanding so we're able to compare
scripture scripture along with history
there's also a practical reason in in
John's day he's writing some of these
things about the Roman power so some of
the things are current in his time now
they cover a broad sweep of history but
because he's writing to Christians who
would have been familiar with other
books like the Book of Daniel and
interpreting Bible prophecy that way God
inspires John to write in the same way
so that when the letter go out and the
Romans are like what is all this right
they don't have a clue but spiritual
things are spiritually discerned and to
so to God's people when they get the
letters they like okay we know what this
means because we have the keys to unlock
these symbols we have the tools to
understand prophecy absolutely and even
with that the symbolisms they paint
their own picture they give insight into
the characteristics of what's being
talked about as well so another aspect
and the beautiful thing about it is is
that um studying the books of Daniel
Revelation has helped me to really
understand practically the whole tenor
of the message of the whole Bible is
something and as we are told in
Inspiration that all the books of the
Bible end in meet in Revelation with
Christ as the centner well I've also
heard it explained that you know people
people kind of center around this Beast
conversation that's happening in in
Revelation but really it's a love story
really the the church as the bride of
Christ um is being wooed by a dragon
type character and Jesus is going after
that and and and wanting to win her back
and so if you actually look at it it
really is a love story it it's it's just
I think people kind of dismiss it from
the Beast perspective and it comes full
circle we start in Perfection paradise
and we're going through all the
consequences of the decisions made in
that environment the Revelation ends
with a restoration of that paradise so
to not complete the book and finish the
Bible we're missing out on the punchline
of the whole story going back to what
you said earlier you know there's
there's this if you will Game of Thrones
happening in Revelation especially in
Revelation 4 and 5 there's an unusually
high concentration of the usage of the
term Throne because this is what Satan's
going after right we see this in in
passages like Isaiah 14 you know where
he's he's telling his intention is to go
after God's Throne right and I like this
this picture of how Israel you know they
they make this
request they want to be like the other
nations they want they want a king right
so they get their
King and they go through Many Many Kings
and many failures as a nation and then
they go through a period of time without
a
king then Jesus comes on the
scene and when he's about to be
crucified by
pilate pilate asked them this question
should I crucify your
king and coming full circle they say we
have no King but Caesar
wow then you go from that shortly after
that I mean a period of of days really
if if you connect all the dots in the
Bible to
Jesus in in
heaven receiving the throne in
Revelation 4 and 5 and and essentially
having like that
inauguration type view where he's he's
receiving the throne so they go from you
know it's like he fulfills this whole
davidic
Covenant you know situation by taking
that Throne back you know what's
rightfully rightfully his this a
beautiful picture yes and see Satan's
trying to um usurp that throne in Isaiah
14 it talks about his ultimate plan is
to usurp himself to where he will set
his throne above the stars of God and so
in Revelation we see how Isaiah 141
12-14 plays out so just from my study of
the Bible Isaiah 12-4 which is
universally known as the fall of Lucifer
and the history of Lucifer um it's
culminated in the mark of the beast
Christ is where he ultimately seeks to
set himself above God and this is where
worship comes in and so Revelation 13
talks about that number of Distinction
dealing with the number 666 and as on
the screen here on the number 666 um in
ancient paganism was connected with the
sun and listen to this um CD Brooks The
Late CD Brooks said that man was
determined not to follow the B
so they took the first day of the week
and devoted it to an idol which was the
son and listen to this right here now
want to show you two quick things now
this is a baptist ministers uh admission
Dr ET hiscock author of the Baptist
manual that there was and is a command
to keep holy the Sabbath day but that
Sabbath day was not Sunday it will
however be readily said and with some
show of Triumph that the Sabbath was
transferred from the seventh to the
first day of the week thank God for him
being honest with all his duties
Privileges and sanctions earnestly
Desiring information on this subject
which I have studied for many years I
ask where can the record of such a
transaction be found he says not in the
New Testament absolutely not there is no
scriptural evidence of the change of the
Sabbath institution from the 7th to the
first day of the week and then he just
comes right out with it of course I
quite well know that Sunday did come
into use in early Christian history as a
religious day as we learn from Christian
fathers and other sources but what a
Pity that it comes branded with the mark
of paganism and Christian with the name
of the son God then adopted and
Sanctified by the papal apostasy and
bequeathed as a sacred Legacy to
protestantism and that's why they can
say that you may read the Bible from
Genesis to Revelation the Catholic
Church miss this and you will not find a
single line authorizing the
sanctification of Sunday and looking at
this this is a medallion from the Roman
Empire so when John the Revelator heard
was heard the number 666 I believe he
knew it was tied to this number and the
numbers of the zodiac 1 the 36 you put
it together it adds up to 666 in ancient
paganism we have a more sure word of
Prophecy that's why as as Believers in
the word of God we can confidently share
the world without offense letting people
know that there are people who don't
know about this God is Not condemning
them we're here to Enlighten them so
they won't be a part of the counterfeit
Kingdom that Satan wants to put together
which is Babylon yeah 666 really being a
um you know a number that is used like
by Satan right it's like his it's like
his way of thinking and his way of
thinking is really um you know my world
is is is the top dog I don't care what
anybody else says I'm going to go get
mine before you got to get yours you
know it's this kind of like mentality
that's happening I I heard this and
maybe you can expand on this a little
bit um the 666 um really is Man was
created on the 6th day so that seat that
shakina Glory where that's God's
dwelling place inside of our mind it's
like writing no man's Top Dog in the
seat of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit and that's that's interesting
because in Revelation 13 it says the
number 666 is a number of a man that's
right showing that the number 666 is
connected with the beast power the head
of the beast power which is that man
which is the um the pope of Rome himself
meaning watch this right here to go
along with the Pope Sabbath which is
Sunday because he changed it would be
putting man in the place of Christ
because he said he is a man that sits in
the seat of God and calling himself God
God that's right and so we thank God
that as not that I came to all this when
I first started studying the Bible but
as you obey and follow the light and
share God gives you more Revelation to
deepen the conviction so you can with
confidence share with the world what's
getting ready to come and we have to we
can't be ashamed of it because you know
why we're not to bash anybody we're not
to bash nobody and a lot of people think
they know what the mark of the beast is
but it's coming in a different way and
the Bible tells us in Revelation the
penalty Revelation 14 as you go to the
screen the Bible makes it very plain
that if a person receives the mark of
the beast these plagues we're not going
to get into the details of them these
flages are going to fall upon man and
then God says they will be tormented
within the Lake of Fire do you
understand this God's intense hatred
brothers and sisters of why we are to
follow him and not man but this is where
this issue is headed to in these last
days and um thank God and just going
back again going back again in
Revelation the crescendo chapter 13 that
Crescendo shows the two major powers
that will be utilized that will bring on
the End of Time the papacy Roman
Catholicism and the United States mainly
what's called a poate protestantism
meaning that in the United States the
Protestant churches will apostas from
from Protestant principles and unite
themselves with the state as the papacy
has done to enforce the Margot to Beast
through legislative Sunday worship I
thought it was pretty interesting
somebody showed me one time of the um
the Cardinals and how the two colors
that they use are scarlet and
uh purple purple and I thought that was
really crazy because the Bible says that
you know there's this you know apostate
Church basically the woman a harlot
woman who's dressed in purple and red
and I mean that is a very interesting
observation that Revelation gives us of
this end time church right in Revelation
chapter 17 talks about it and it's so
powerful but here's the scary part the
Bible says in Revelation 17 that this
woman which is symbolic of a church
she's a which means she's an
apostate Church um the Bible makes it
very plain that she sits upon seven
heads and 10 horns and the powerful
thing about this is we can know exactly
who it is just based on the geography
the 10 horns when you go to Daniel
coming into Revelation shows you that
this power comes out of Western Europe
but here's the doozy right here the
seven heads the Bible says are Seven
Hills wow what Seven Hill City do we
have Western Europe yeah just one what's
name Rome Rome so that tells you the
geographical location now but if it's a
church she wears purple and Scarlet hold
on what's a ma the major Church in the
city of Rome M the Catholicism and did
you know and I'm sure sure you know that
the major colors of the priesthood is
purple and Scarlet just like Jesus said
so it's Zer end showing that this system
will seek for
worldwide control and unfortunately as
you see she sits upon many Waters
meaning that the whole world's going to
receive the mark of the beast except for
a final few but thank God Revelation
does not end with that the Bible says as
you look in the picture that the world
powers will turn on her and she will be
defeated one of the things that the
thing that I see in Revelation is that
Jesus wins in the end of in the end of
the day he wins but we do have to talk
about what's coming so we won't be on
the losing side so once we know who the
winning side is come on we can know that
okay we can bring other say look here
let's come over to the winning side and
by identifying these things I just thank
God for the truth as it is in Jesus amen
go ahead amen no I I think it's really
important like we brought up earlier
about why some of these things are
hidden in the Bible um you know I think
God did that for for a purpose because
it was written so many years ago it
would be impossible to judge what
happens in the earth I mean that would
just be impossible we can't we can't
even judge like what's going to happen
in next 10 years right like thousands of
years ago this was set in stone like
this is going to happen and this group
is going to do this and you know this
deadly wound that's inflicted upon this
church will be healed and they will gain
power again in the end time and I mean
those are the things that we are
actually witnessing right now it's
pretty pretty amazing to be alive today
something that's really fascinating
about the Book of Revelation is that
Satan has many aspects where he's
essentially imitating God right so like
this whole mark of the beast issue
people get tripped up on this they don't
know they don't know what it is so they
read popular Christian books to try to
figure out what it is but if you study
the Bible these things are there right
you can find them and many of these
things are rooted in the Old Testament
exactly so for example the mark of the
beast how do you know it's not some
microchip or barcode or something like
that well where does that symbolism even
come from right comes from Deuteronomy
chapter 6 that's right so Deuteronomy
chapter 5 God's repeated The Ten
Commandments okay then in Deuteronomy
chapter 6 he says some interesting words
he says in these words so what words is
he talking about the words he just spoke
on the mountain Ten Commandments Comm he
says these words which I command you
today shall be in your heart okay
everybody Christians are agreeable with
that right right you shall teach them
diligently to your children and you
shall talk of them when you sit in your
house when you walk by the way when you
lie down and when you rise up makes a
lot of sense right a lot of sense teach
the kids okay you shall bind them as a
sign on your hand and they shall be as
frontlets between your eyes you shall
write them on the doorpost of your house
and on your Gates just like okay here we
just saw the same
symbolism around the hand and his
frontlets between the eyes so what is
God trying to to say well what he's
trying to say is look these words that I
spoke I want you to teach them to your
children so that they'll do them with
their hand and think about them after
you've taught them to them because what
you think about is going to affect what
you do ultimately right that's all God's
getting at yeah words and actions must
match yeah words and actions must match
so when this is in when this comes down
the pipe later on in Revelation 13 the
beast is just saying look I want you to
think like I want you to think and I
want you to do what I want you to do
because I'm imitating God in the way God
works that's power and if you don't do
you're going to get in trouble you're
going to get in trouble and that's a
powerful parallel we didn't have there
was no guesstimation on that we just go
right to the scripture to the word right
to the scripture so that we don't have
to guess and that's a powerful powerful
explanation one might ask is it really
that simple just worshiping on on Sunday
in the same way like is it was it really
does the consequence match the action
of just biing a pie of fruit in theard
of Eden uh yes and no in that it's
obedience that's what it boils down to
obedience and when you think about what
obedience leads to worship and then who
are you worshiping that that's really
all it is at the end of the day and the
devil's not going to make it easy on you
he's not because in Revelation 13 he's
not just bringing like okay there
there's going to be penalty he's
bringing Miracles exactly you know like
hey I'm going to get you one way or the
other I'm going to get you by signs and
wonders or I'm going to get you by hey
you better do it or else but even that
is the Bible gives us an answer to in
the same book Deuteronomy Revelation 13
Deuteronomy 13 look it up right what do
you have happening he says you know the
Beast is going to call fire down from
heaven yes right Deuteronomy 13 if there
arises among you a prophet or a dreamer
of dreams and he gives you a sign or a
Wonder it's exactly what it's talking
about you get a sign or a wonder and the
sign or wonder comes to pass of which he
spoke to you saying let us go after
other gods which you have not known and
let us serve them we're talking about
the same thing right this thing comes to
pass and it's about worship that's what
going after other gods is it's about
worship goes on you shall not listen to
that words of that Prophet or that
dreamer of dreams for the Lord your God
is testing you to know whether you love
the Lord your God with all your heart
and with all your soul you shall walk
after the Lord your God now catch this
language because this is the same stuff
that's in Revelation 14 and fear Him and
keep his Commandments and obey his voice
you shall hold you shall serve him and
hold fast to him but then here's what it
says of that Prophet but that Prophet or
that dreamer of Dreams shall be put to
death because he has spoken in an order
to turn you away from the Lord your God
who brought you out of the land of Egypt
and redeemed you from the house of
bondage to entice you from the way in
which the Lord your God commanded you to
walk so you shall put away the evil from
your midst so you have this picture of
the children of Israel on the edge of of
the River Jordan when balum gets invited
to go and curse them right and uh
balam's just like you know baffled by uh
you know he wants the money the
midianite kings are offering and
promising know all these things but he's
like look I can only do what God wants
me to do and he's just uttering
blessings to the midianite kings are
very upset go home if we see you again
probably be your last day well he goes
home thinks about it and he says comes
back to him and he says you know the
best way that you can engage with them
and have power over them is to get them
to worship something other than their
God so to answer your question about is
the Sunday sacredness is it is it is it
really a big deal we're talking about
the protection that Israel had at the
River Jordan was unprecedented there
every Army on the planet could have come
against them and no one could have
touched them but the second they engaged
in worshiping something other than God
they l thate lost that protection and
then boom there was a huge apostasy go
ahead we see a mirroring happening and
we need to understand the old well we
need to know the old understand the old
to help us understand the New Testament
what would you say in response to
someone who's thinking well if I have an
understanding of the old right reading
Deuteronomy I already have it in place
it's in my lifestyle it's my
understanding to not give worship to
anyone other than God X Y and Z do I
really need to know the intricacies
happening in Revelation in terms of what
the Beast means and what's going to
happen exactly because God put it out
there for he said blessed is he which
read and hear so he expects you to read
and expects you to understand so you can
apply it so you can be blessed so God
has given us reasoning powers to go
through scripture just like my brother
here did for the purpose of unlocking so
that we will know who it is like for
instance if there was a a convicted
rapist serial rapist running around town
especially to protect our young ladies I
want to know size I want to know
everything even
details so that if I see him knocking on
my door then we can do what we have to
do keep them away and I don't think
anybody's going to get to the end here I
I think that's the phenomenon of God
right he is he is sharing information in
such a way that the only fair thing is
for you to have a choice that's right
but you can't have a choice if you don't
have the information so I don't think
you're going to get to the end of the
the end of your life and plead Sorry God
I didn't know no right this stuff is you
know it's right there in the Bible it's
been there for thousands of years and
right you know we need to study it and
we need to study it and so going back to
something you was alluding to I want to
go to the screen here because people say
well does this thing really make a
difference well the Bible does um he's
very specific now you know there's only
one day he Sanctified blessed in um said
Sanctified blessed in rest and that is
the Sabbath and we can go to
Creation where Jesus died on Good Friday
Good Friday the preparation day on the
Sabbath he rest now in Matthew Mark Luke
and John it's bless you in the Book of
Mark the Bible says he rose upon the
first day of the week which in in his
time order is the day after the Sabbath
showing that the seventh day of the
weekly cycle is the 7day Sabbath so I
don't want to deviate too far off from
this point but I'd like you to clarify
something there was a some discussion in
the comment section on one of our
previous videos talking about the the
death and resurrection of Jesus um the
the days were instituted in Genesis
chapter 1 evening and morning were the
first day second so for there are some
people who believe that Jesus actually
died was it Wednesday night beginning of
Thursday therefore he's in the Tomb for
3 Days uh what would you how would you
resp very simple in the parable of the
on the parable of the marketplace about
the um those who went out in the third
hour 6th hour 11th Hour they all got a
penny right and those at the 11th Hour
got paid for a whole day's wage so um
Josephus and just Jewish thought was is
that any part of a day was considered a
whole 24 hours so Friday Saturday and
Sunday even though to us may have been
less than 72 hours was considered that
based on Jewish thought do you
understand that so but even in the
parable of Matthew 20 we see that played
out to where a person worked only one
hour but got paid as if he worked for a
full day so it's that's how you do it
thank you I question I also think there
is so much um symbolism that God has
designed into this thing I mean in the
Jewish economy every single thing in
their life pointed to some sort of
spiritual truth whe they dug in the dirt
or they you know had a day of rest for
the plants or whatever like that just
told them some some spiritual truth and
so yeah Jesus he didn't die on a Tuesday
he he he he died on a day that he rested
and then rose again you know and so it's
like he gave us this Memorial of the
Sabbath day that I believe throughout
eternity we're going to we're going to
have this day that we're going to
remember what our savior did for us and
so you know I think the whole thing just
gets disrupted when you start yes you
know picking different days that he was
on there and it also says you know the
Jews wanted to take down the body
because they were worried about the
Sabbath right um and so there's a lot of
there's a lot of evidence even just in
the Bible that tells us that that
happened on Friday it's using our biases
and culture to interpret the Bible
instead of keeping it within its cont I
think that's a very powerful Point
biases in culture I mean this though
it's very clear right there that Sunday
is definitely not the day of worship I
mean because it's so universally done
people do it as if it is truth and so
it's what it is but going back to what
you talking about I mean just as there
was a God was specific about the fruit
as you see on the screen Sunday is the
forbidden day according to Bible
prophecy because it will be the mark of
the beast when Sunday laws are enforced
what will it be called we don't know but
the bottom line is this right here
Sunday will be legalized as a day of
worship and then as we transition I want
to just show you how close we're coming
to this because in Revelation just
looking at it exetic
a beaste is symbolic of a kingdom Daniel
7 tells us this we see a beaste
enforcing worship so hold on if a
kingdom enforces worship that's a
violation of our first amendment rights
so we see religion enforced by law which
in this country would be the union of
church and state violating the
separation of church and state so we
know that the church State issue will be
the issue when it comes to bringing this
Market to be Sunday law crisis you want
to say something yeah I'm I'm I'm just
you know one of the things that's always
struck me in the Bible that you people
say h you know it's really not that big
a deal so you know don't worry about it
but I think it's I think it's numbers 15
you know this the children of Israel
they find this guy who's gathering
firewood on the Sabbath bring him to
Moses they're like what do we do with
him Moses goes to God and God says Stone
him I'm like that seems really
harsh right mm like
why why did God say that you know did he
say it because it's just really not that
big a deal I mean I mean what's I mean
he was just picking up sticks no God
said Stone him and I think it's largely
because of his attitude he
knew you know it's not like everybody
was ignorant he knew did it anyway no
I'm going to do things my way like Cain
right M but it mattered because God
said this is what you're to do this is
the Sabbath this is the day you're going
to that you're supposed to be worshiping
right so I think that's it's kind of a
powerful point and and something very
sobering to think about that God's like
no he picked up
sticks he gets the axe yeah I I like
that you you brought out that point that
it's it's it's displaying something much
greater into his heart
and I think that's why the punishment
was metered out in that way is like that
type of rebellious Spirit if that is you
know infectuous in the group it can just
taint I mean a little tiny piece of Le
right makes the whole whole thing go
crazy and so I think he dealt harshly
because of where he was trying to bring
those people and they had a lot of
evidence in front of them like you see
God with lightning bolts flying around
and telling you you know you need to do
this and that uh how many of you are
going to come up to the to the thing be
like I don't really feel like doing what
you're saying yeah but to say it doesn't
matter and then just kind of casually
dismiss it and go on with your own ideas
and say I'm going to do what I want I
don't think that's the attitude we
should have with God no but I'd like to
hear your thoughts on this um because we
can agree that there should be a
separation between church and state but
can there ever be should there be a good
balance where there is an influence like
the church influences the state in that
if you look at the history of the United
States um how civilization was how there
was prayer in school X Y and Z and how
that uh positively influenced society
and we have that being removed in the
last 20 years and we see how Society has
gone without that influence um what
would how how would you respond to that
where okay no church and state but
without the influence of the church we
see what happens to the state see what
happens is that those things are good in
their place but what we see in
Revelation chapter 13 we see a thing
where coercion comes so you know if you
let a little snake egg in the chicken
coop and it comes to life or you know it
hatches it's innocent for a while but
give it some time and it becomes a
predator so what happens is that in the
end of time I want to really make sure I
answer your question um um succinct but
I want to just be honest
that knowing what's coming down the
pipeline even things that are good in
their place come in we know they're
going to take it to the extreme to where
we will see intrusion because what
happens is is that what we see here is
the issue of freedom of conscience to
where worship is
enforced by law and right now dealing
now when to show going to get to
something here there's a movement called
make America pray again okay it's okay
it's okay to encourage America to pray
but to make them pray hold on the person
says I'm an atheist I don't believe in
any God why should I pray somebody says
well I believe in prayer but I don't
believe in praying to the Christian God
I may serve another deity you see what
I'm saying so these things are good in
their place but what happens is looking
at how things are moving and what
prophecy says is going to go to the
point where it's going to be one way or
no way at all that's right the human
nature is the culprit yes yeah but
that's a good question love it I want to
dive into this clip go ahead all right
want to just show you a clip here this
is um uh presidential candidate Donald J
Trump where he promises to Grant
Christians namely the Christian
nationalist I don't know on another
program you talked about that um which
is a a movement that seeks to control
the state and that's that's I we need to
go over that groundwork but just adding
that he wants to give them unprecedented
political power watch closely clarify
who them is oh give Donald Trump wants
to give who power the Rel Christians he
wants to Grant Christians the religious
mainly the
evangelicals unprecedented political
power and it plays into the
2025 U the project 2025 agenda watch
closely ladies and gentlemen with your
help and God's grace the great Revival
of America begins on November 5th
[Applause]
2024 be able to do it because you're the
people we want to hear from the pastors
and the ministers and the rabbis the
people in this room are the people we
want to hear from and they have to have
a political voice you know if you think
about it you have men you have women and
you have religion if you look at it you
have more than the men you have more
than the women you have such power but
you really you weren't allowed to use
that power and you're now allowed to use
it I get in there you're going to be
using that power at a level that you've
never used it before it's going to bring
back the churchgoer I mean you have to
see I bring back the churchgoer okay
what's the traditional people go to
church yeah see what I'm saying and it
kind of all fits so let me ask you a
question how do you see just um just we
only 48 seconds into it he says a lot
more how do you see this playing into
the end time scenario see I see that do
I believe that he knows exactly where
this is going no but we can see as
students of Prophecy knowing what's
getting ready to come that okay this is
the
embryo and if God allows it it will
hatch to it will excuse me mature to a
full-grown baby what do you want to say
about this this is this is some scary
stuff because he's talking about I'm
going to give you power and then with
that power you get to do X Y and Z and
it's like domination Christ promised us
power as as as Christians as followers
of him we are tapped into the power that
he exuded here on Earth but what did
Christ use that power for it wasn't for
political domination and all these
things foring people worship exactly
what are we supposed to use our Rel
religious power so to speak for and
that's so clear in James 1: 27 it's
supposed to be used to visit the orphans
and the widows to do good to others and
of course to keep ourselves unspotted
from the world yeah I like that you went
there because it's it's exactly Jesus
had that opportunity was when he was
here on this Earth he could have just
said you know what we're going to get
rid of the Romans and just set up the
kingdom like the way it's supposed to
and they're modeling this after the same
way whereas Christ is trying to change
individual hearts Minds he's not trying
to set up a political system or a
political Kingdom or anything like that
he's already got the kingdom established
right you know new Jerusalem's coming
he's got that part figured out it's done
will you know what he needs is to
populate it with the right kind of
people but the right kind of people
aren't the power hungry people who just
want to force their way on everybody
that's right and we want to say this
that what we're saying here when we come
to this part is not
um picking one side over the other which
is analyzing showing how prophecy is
progressively being fulfilled in
movements regardless of what side it's
on yep the real war is fought for the
throne of your mind it's really where
where God wants to reside it's really
what Satan's trying to usurp he's trying
to put his throne on our thoughts on our
way and and and super forceful about it
that's why I love the image of Jesus
knocking on the door of your heart
that's right such a gentleman he's so
kind about it like he's like look if you
don't want me to be in your life I will
respect that right and I won't force my
way in there that's not how the devil
works at all exactly to that point and
what you said Keith about uh Power
hungry people are not fit citizens for
the Kingdom of Heaven neither are robots
right and so legislating and putting
these laws people obey out of fear they
don't want to be put in prison what have
you you're producing robots people whose
choice has been taken away exactly which
really takes away the image of God
because image of God was Man was created
in that image to reflect his likeness
through Choice that's why the tree of
knowledge of Geva is the test and going
back to what you said in Deuteronomy 13
in principle this end time Mark to be
Sunday law crisis is a test for the
world do we fear God more than man God
is love and Bible says that perfect love
casts out fear yes because fear has
torment so fear is not part of God's
love equation right it's not so let's
continue on in this video see I don't
like the charts when I see charts where
they're going in the wrong direction we
don't like that we're going to bring it
back and I really believe it's the
biggest thing missing from this country
it's the biggest thing missing we have
to bring back our religion we have to
bring back Christianity in this
country thank
you thank you very much and I make you a
simple promise in my first term I fought
for Christians harder than any president
has ever done before you know that you
know that and I will fight even harder
for Christians with four more years in
the white house we did things that uh
the likes of which nobody has ever done
for Christians in this country and I'm
very proud of that and honored by it
evangelists like the late great Pat
Robertson who is a great gentleman got
to know him very well
great
evangelist and of course Billy graah how
good was Billy graah
right I remember my father took me to
Yankee Stadium and Billy graah was
preaching and it was amazing I was very
young my father loved Billy gra and that
place was packed bigger than any World
Series game bigger than anything
anybody's ever seen and it was packed
and uh we would love to bring it back to
those days Jack right would love to
bring it back to those days love to
bring it back to those days and so what
happens is this gives an impetus for as
prophecy has foretold us the religious
power will seek to control the Civil
power and this is playing right into the
prophetic scenario just as the enemy
would have it and who are who are you to
fight against you know like everybody
needs God everybody does need God like
like this this on the outward appearance
this looks like a really good idea we
need to bring God back into the equation
and but what they're going with that is
just an absolute and utter forcefulness
with it which I completely disagree with
exactly and so you know with this in
mind there are movements at work I'm not
saying this is the only movement but is
coming from a standpoint we know that
the mark of the beast Sunday worship of
course be religious but what happens is
the enemy understanding that lot is a
great Mass of humanity that may not be
sold at from a religious standpoint but
if we can do it from a standpoint that
could be B borders on the secular around
a common cause then we probably can get
people I found this article as we go to
the screen I'm not going to play the
video but you can play play it what if I
told you that the next big climate move
could be simply doing nothing so imagine
this one day each week where you do less
and the planet gets more that's the
proposal of one Jewish religious and
intellectual history Professor it's the
old school charm of the Sabbath with
kind of a new age green twist now this
isn't just lounging around it's actually
a conscious choice to reduce our
environmental impact no checking emails
watching TV or driving for a whole day
in theory we could slash our carbon
emissions by a whopping
14.3% that's 17th of our weekly output
Gone without spending a dime or needing
any new techn technology so just one day
out of seven where we nearly eliminate
emissions it's an old ritual with a new
role in our fight against climate change
so what do you think would you take a
day off for the Earth it's on the
Weather Channel It's called EOS Sabbath
how to cut emissions by doing
nothing and look what it says what if
every week we all United how who is all
the world for a single day hold on now
this is where Force comes in everybody's
not sold on the Sabbath principle on a
particular day because you have
different Persuasions but we know in the
end time will be on Sunday to
conscientiously avoid activities that
support the fossil fuel industry it is a
conscious choice that for many would be
a big departure from the normal but in
theory taking a day of rest could have
major impacts against the fight on the
fight against climate change what do you
want to say about I like how they thrw
in there just in theory like we don't
really know if this is going to work but
we're just going to make you do it
anyway you they don't yeah I saw this
presentation um by uh Walter V that was
really interesting he talked about the
plant life and he was describing how the
plants um their job their function is to
pull the carbon out of the air carbon
dioxide out of the air and then convert
it and turns into plant food and they
spit out oxygen right and and he was
like it's Preposterous to think that
that that there's too much of this
carbon dioxide in the air there would be
more plants all of a sudden plants would
because they're going to respond to it
you're giving them more food it's like
giving them fertilizer and then they're
all of a sudden going to just like
Thrive and he's like it's it's it's like
they're using the science but in in sort
of this like blanket
unscientific way to push that agenda but
if you actually sat down and considered
the the actual real science of what's
going on it's it's not the case yeah but
nevertheless they're pushing it and now
what we just showed you was promoted
back in 20 9 as you go to the screen it
says slow Sunday The Simple Solution to
global warming and that's what they all
these cop 28 meetings 29 30 whatever
it's going to be in the future it says
using Sunday as a day of rest and
renewal will be good for our personal
health as well as the health of the
planet and so that just shows me how the
enemy is working in other ways to bring
the Sunday concept to be accepted
practically almost outside of a
religious context and just recently I
found this website let's go back to the
screen again it's called Earth Sabbath a
weekly rest one day a week from the for
the Earth do you hear this and I'm not
going to you can go to this right here
and it talks about see that right there
the person snoozing right and combat
climate change Earth Sabbath give the
earth a weekly rest one day a week every
week reduce energy consumption 17th to
help combat climate change and then it
says Earth Sabbath is for everyone all
of us can participate people of all ages
as instruments of care giving the earth
a rest a rest one day a week according
to each person's own culture religion
experiences involvements and talents and
this right here on this website they
promote Earth Sabbath marches now watch
this now on this and I'm not going to
get into um this you can watch this
video go to Earth sabbath. world they
talk about this concept to where they
propose to use April 7
2024 as the Earth Sabbath March day for
the whole world like a literal March
like a literal March like um here um
Greta thunberg uh Fridays for the future
and other kind of protest marches this
may or may not uh um fly but what
happens is that you can watch these
videos I'm not going to get into these
videos but what happens is they're
demanding a day of rest for the earth
now what does that sound like well
forceful worship and you are going to be
looked at as somebody who doesn't care
about your fellow neighbor if you don't
want to observe this particular thing
then you don't care about the earth I
still don't correct me from wrong but
even regardless of the day even how
they're saying this should be observed
is a counterfeit because it's pushing
isolation where what are we supposed to
be doing on the Sabbath Gathering
Together doing good for uh our fellow
mankind like
I don't know this this is how are
emissions reduced by us staying home if
anything everyone's using their own
electricity yeah here's the thing during
the pandemic they put information out
there that by all these lockdowns they
showed that's true before and after
Waters that were very muddy were clear
so it kind of plays in into that and
what's funny about it was is that during
the pandemic they had what was called um
they would have what's called Sunday
lockdowns to where they will lock down
one day a week to stop a virus that goes
going around seven days a week and it's
interesting how in different various
parts of the world you have these
lockdowns going on I'm like why Sunday
they may not know but the prophetic eye
that God has given us let's be known I
believe that the enemy is just this is
his groundwork Preparing People for the
idea of Sunday observance once the
United States enforces it and then
everybody would have been conditioned
already to follow their example yeah
there's clearly some problems with this
idealism like you talked about so you
know it's like if you're going to give
the earth a rest then then what is
everybody really supposed to do does
that mean you're just not going to work
does it mean you're you can't go to
church then you can't
breathe breathing me really what does
that mean because it's like if you're
trying to encourage people to take a day
off and rest but then you have the you
know the political machine saying we
need to get people back in church well
they're still moving around they're
still going places they're still putting
gas in their cars to get there still
ordering online and expecting their
packages to show up right so you know I
get I get I kind of get their logic but
at the same time it's also saying if you
do it on a different day you're not
making a difference at all you're not
making or if you don't want to do it at
all now let's go back to the screen here
now the last thing I'm going to show you
is is the earth Sabbath marches we are
asking people everywhere to organize an
earth Sabbath for March for Sunday April
7 2024 feel free to do a March anytime
but we're trying to get the word out for
a global march on this day at 11:00 a.m.
of course 11:00 a.m. is the time people
go to church organize or participate in
an earth Sabbath March in your City
Community Church school or university
creating an awareness and notice that
word
demanding people to take action in
support of a weekly Earth Sabbath day
one day a week everyone needs to protect
ipate and keep Earth sabath to achieve
Real Results doesn't that kind of sound
like borderline Force yes and what's
really confusing about this is blending
the word Sabbath into this they're not
talking about Saturday right they're not
talking about a day of worship known to
many people who observe the sabbath as
the seventh day of the week but they're
blending those two concepts together
because uh I I I saw a clip one time of
the Pope talking about you know the Jews
took a break and and this was very
beneficial to them and they took a
Sabbath and uh so we we want to take
that Sabbath as well but those were two
totally different days but he was
blending the ideas together by calling
what the cath Catholic Church was doing
was a Sabbath a comment came to mind as
as you were speaking Scotty um them
being intentional intentional about
saying Earth Sabbath and uh the word
Christian now being used as a political
point to tell people what they want to
hear now imagine having a conversation
with someone and saying oh I'm a Sabbath
keeper or or I'm a Christian mhm I am
too now what does that mean oh you're
Christian militant Force oh I keep the
Sabbath oh I can't do X Y and Z or else
I'll be uh arrested or whatever the
consequence will be it's going to become
very difficult to share truth
when and another reason why it's going
to be difficult to share truth is
because now you know Satan has been
employing
deception since the beginning and one of
the most diabolical things to do
is a lie a lie is a very diabolical act
I think out of all the sins I mean every
sin is bad but the one of the most
diabolical thing to do is to just give
falsehood now when we go to the screen
right here when you type up what is the
seventh day of the week Google says
Sunday the international standard ISO
8601 for representation of dates and
time state that Sunday is the seventh
and last day of the week contrary to
scripture wow and but hold on look here
and look here and when you look at this
this is a you know what planet it is
right that's planet Earth yeah all the
countries you see in blue where North
America and South hard of South America
these are all the countries where the
calendar has Sunday as the first day and
Saturday as the 7th but in all those
countries where you see the lighter
colors those are all where the calendars
reflect Sunday as the seventh day so so
I wonder too you see that right there on
the um screen right there Monday as the
first Sunday as the first so the blue
Sunday is the first day which means
Saturday 7th but on the blue right here
you will see the the lighter colors
Monday is the first day of the week so
are those generally known as um Catholic
run um countries well we know South
America is and we see um most of South
parts of South America which I believe
are Catholic countries so the Catholic
influence is there Europe mhm now China
um I believe of course China is commant
so it wouldn't say it's that Catholic
influence but what happen happens is
it's a luciferian influence they may not
be doing it for Catholic reason or based
on Catholic tradition but it just may be
just how they've chosen it to do just to
be in in alignment you know what I'm
saying it's it's very it's that's this
is diabolical this is very diabolical so
when the Sunday law comes when the mark
of the beast comes the world the
majority is already prepared for it it's
easy for them it'd be easier because
psychologically when I was a child even
though Sunday was at at the beginning I
thought that was the seventh day of the
week myself as a child because it had
read on it because it was special just
looking at those old calendars back in
the days so what happens is is that the
enemy is fighting against the word so we
have to go to the word and the word
itself and this Sunday law crisis is
going to be so deceptive even to those
of us that believe it's going to
challenge us to see do we really believe
the things that we're saying even in
this broadcast M that's why on Christ
the solid rock I Stand All as they can I
I want to challenge anybody that that is
watching this conversation and and and
maybe you go to church on Sunday um you
know this might be a stark conversation
for you right off the bat but challenge
yourself like truth pray that God can
can show you truth and and and try to go
through the Bible and really study this
out is there verses in the Bible that
really support Sunday as the as the day
of worship and you know do yourself
Justice like look into it don't just
assume whatever your pastor or some
other Ministry said you go to the word
of God you get on your hands and knees
and you pray God is there truth here in
this thing and uh I think you'll come to
the same conclusion that we're we're
speaking about today yes and um the last
thing I want to present before we
because I know we have a limited amount
of time you know um when the Bible says
blessed that they wish to read and hear
the words of this prophecy I believe
part of the blessing is is that God will
give you confirmation over and over and
over every week I either read something
find something or somebody sends me
something that correlates with what we
talking about right now two months ago
in the month of January on the
Washington Post so you know this is not
fake news listen what this says right
here why a day of rest could help
climate change and we in our faith
tradition know from a book called The
Great controversy knows that a law will
be given or and proposed to stop these
what they called Earth calamities which
they now call climate change so we put
these things together and by looking at
this I'm like Lord this thing is really
coming and so God has his way you see
the the Protestants um seeking control
they putting their candidates in power
they even have as um as the project 2025
plan has a six month plan they already
have it 900 pages on it's really their
man esto and so am I saying it's going
to happen during the Republican
presidency I'm not saying it because in
such an hour as we think not the time
that we think not it can happen but what
happens is God is showing us just as the
image was built in Daniel 3 it wasn't
built overnight it was built Brick by
Brick the Hebrew boys knew that worship
was coming legalized worship so God is
allowing these things to come to pass to
show that something is coming and here's
the power one of you talked about how
Satan's going to use deception
and the Bible says in Matthew 24 If any
man shall say unto you Lo Christ is here
or there believe it not and notice this
why would Jesus say that because the
devil's going to do it look at this
slide right here if they shall say to
you Christ is there don't believe it not
just don't believe it don't even go
don't investigate thank you don't turn
on the TV that's right look at this
Christ at the United Nations I saw this
on Facebook somebody Drew this picture
and all on the thread people were saying
amen amen amen amen I almost said it
myself but I said hold on now though
they may say Christ is needed for the
world we know that when Satan comes as
an angel of Light I believe that one of
the things he would
do appear before the kings of the earth
and say that we need to go along with
this Sunday law agenda
and we're in the final crisis what do
you want what do y'all want to say about
that part this is real this is some this
is real this is not the first time in
history that this has happened you know
this is this has been laying dormant for
many many many years in fact this has
already gone to state supreme court
level it's already come before Congress
there are many laws that are already on
the books right now about blue laws or
Sunday
laws this whole concept was um
uh was almost passed as a national
Sunday law back in the late 1800s right
if it were not for the testimony of one
man who is very versed in the Bible and
history and you can look that up it's
called The Blair Bill and that nearly
happened in this country and in and in
many states at the Supreme Court level
level it was upheld Sunday laws were
upheld and they were not upheld for
religious reasons they were upheld for
civil reasons right which is what you
see the Christian nationalist or project
25 that's all the direction they're
trying to go too because they know that
it would immediately be a violation of
people's Bill of Rights that's right so
they're trying to come at it from a
different angle where you can't fight it
right and so just you know if you look
in history this isn't the first time
it's happened it's not so it's just
coming back again and look at this New
York Times this is the actual article of
course they saved it on they saved the
file Mar May 22nd 1888 New York Times
stop work on Sunday Senator Blair wants
the Lord's Day strictly observed and
this is where he put a bill before
Congress so as you said this is not the
first time and of course they presented
it of course as a day of worship and
rest but they also did it as a civil to
get everybody on their same platform
what you want to say sister Dr o you
brought up an excellent point with uh
the three Hebrew boys and the idol the
statue golden statue being built how it
wasn't an overnight thing it was Brick
by Brick therefore for the three Hebrew
boys it wasn't a surprise uh it wasn't a
snap decision when they decided not to
bow down it was a daily decision that
they had to make the Bible says Thy word
have I hid in my heart that I may not
sin against you to hide something in
your heart you need to read it you need
to meditate it it needs to become a part
of who you are and the time is now the
process needs to happen now before we
even get to that point so when a
decision does need to be made that final
decision we will be prepared and able to
make it easily exactly and God writing
the laws on our heart right why would he
write the laws on our heart but be like
oh the fourth one that's a kind of an
old law you can just skip over that one
or whatever right he's right not one jot
or one tit will by no means pass from
the law like like that that Ten
Commandments is important to God just as
much as it was on Mount Si and even back
in the beginning of of of time with Adam
and Eve as it is to for us today um and
I like that you brought up Daniel and
Shadrach Meshach and a minut ago I think
when you read the book of Daniel you
realize that their first their first
introduction to society they're making
small choices with their food why
because those small choices daily are
given to you over and over and over
again so that you can strengthen
yourself with the big decisions if you
can't make those small decisions right
now how are you going to stand when
times really get stressful and
somebody's really sticking a gun to your
head
I think the story of Shadrach Meshach
and abedo is is an illustration of going
they purposed in their heart early on
right we need to solidify the purposes
of our heart to know we serve God
because if you think you're going to do
it when this time comes about it will
not happen in that confusion they were
making what's called I call it a
christocentric conditioning process
because Christ they were Christians in
their heart and knowing that the
supremacy of Christ is Chief in my life
they were able to submit to the power of
the indwelling Christ within them to
make the right choices so when the great
test came they were able to make the
same stand with the same uh fervor and
determination I think that's a lesson
for us Christ with the New Covenant
experience must be written within the
heart no way in the world we can say no
yeah but as we go to the screen here
these young people said no and that's
going to be our test in the last days
you know in that story there was no
conflict within those three men uh what
they believed did not conflict with
their actions they were in total
alignment so there's this uh joke I
heard growing up that uh one would
wonder why didn't they just like bend
down to strap in their sandals you know
uh they're not bowing down they're just
doing this action but it it it would
have protected them so to speak from the
emminent danger that was approaching and
so in the in the event that the Sunday
law comes and there's this force of rest
or go to church yes if someone says hey
you know I know the truth and and I'm
still keeping the Sabbath on the seventh
day Saturday the Sabbath but um you know
I'll I'll stay home on Sunday or I'll go
to church on Sunday as well what is the
issue with that the issue is is that um
in the day you're going to be compelled
to where you won't be able to buy or
sell you will be compelled to
acknowledge Sunday as the as the Sabbath
and there's more to it but that's going
to be the focal issue and just like the
image of Daniel
chapter uh three they were compelled to
work to go contrary to what God Said and
that's what the market of Beast really
is going contrary cuz see they're going
to enforce what they call the Sabbath
but it's the mark of the beast Sabbath
Sunday and they're going to put a de
decree if if it wasn't so uh uh serious
they wouldn't put a death decree or
economic boycott behind it so they
definitely want to compel your
conscience but we're not going to be
compelled to do anything by the grace of
God because our God shall supply all our
needs
in let's go to the screen in the last
days on Sunday that's where it's coming
to a new America where no buy no sell
and what's very diabolical about it and
I got to show you this do you know that
right now that there are Billboards
putting that seed right now look at that
one Sunday worship is
biblical no Bible text just put it out
there what is that saying well everybody
goes to church on something so it must
be the it must be true what do you want
to say my brother no I I I'm I'm just
kind of taking it what you guys I mean
this conversation could just keep going
and going I love this um but I I like
the idea of of what happened back in
Nebuchadnezzar's day because I I I think
that that's a mini model of what we're
going to be called to do we're going to
have to be called to stand at some point
for what you believe right and when the
king asked these boys you know like okay
take your time I'm going to let you have
a little chance they didn't need to take
their time there was no threat that
would have even changed and I love that
they even stated that you know what our
God is able to say save us but if he
doesn't he does still not going to
trample on God's law and do what you
want what you want king and the king is
so upset I think it's such a beautiful
Story I mean he's just furious right he
he kills his own men trying to make this
like this hot fire situation I'm going
to freak these out right literally I
mean we're talking probably minutes
later he's pulling the boys out praising
God and then telling anybody if you
speak anything against this God Of
Heaven you're going to be made as a
dungill in your house and everything
else right that's that's what that
obedience did it turned the heart of the
king so in a situation where we think
like you know what our life may be
called into into question and yeah we
may get our neck on The Chopping Block
but I tell you what if you are faithful
that will Ripple into um into the into
the world and make absolutely they
didn't fight back they didn't try to
dominate what did they do they obeyed
and Christ stepped in and showed his
majesty that's right tell you this is
very powerful so what we've been doing
with our ministry on Project L rain
Ministries is that we've been seeking to
counteract this to bring awareness to it
and one of the ways that we're doing it
of course through social media Ministry
of course evangelist Ministry using
what's called billboard Ministry um this
is right here um a website that I've
created 666 what isth mark.com
will the Sunday law be the mark of the
beast just asking a question because and
in in this this is what we've been doing
we put one out not too far from here and
so this year we're coming out with some
new ones this is another one right here
is the is Sunday the Lord's day or the
mark of the beast and these are
Billboards these are Billboards that
we're putting out and the one that we
have have out right now is did you know
that the mark of the beast will be
worshiped on Sunday all we're doing is
asking a question to create awareness
we're not bashing notice it's a question
mark a question excuse me so that people
can see because people have been already
conditioned believe the market of be is
something completely different than what
the Bible says and what we're talking
about but to put that there so they can
go to the website and we have two books
um great controversies one of them and
National Sunday law this is our featured
book right here to where we're just
putting seeds there in preparation to
where they may see this video or
somebody may give them a bob say you
know I heard that before somewhere and
we have to allow Christ to do his work
so we're just using every advertising
agency possible and we've been doing
this for about three years now started
off in a little town in Tony Alabama now
we're doing this Nationwide and is
caught on fire and so what you want to
say if somebody wants to um get the
national Sunday law can they find it on
your website or how would they get yes
they can go to 666 what is the mark.com
or they can go to Sunday law update.com
this is another one uh right here and
what we're doing is we want to put these
in various localities um they can go to
Sunday law update.com or they can go to
666 what isthe mark.com and they can
just download it and want to just show
you one of our viewers in popular Bluff
Missouri um he asked me to do this and
we found it and we was able to pay for
it and we have it up right now awes so
we've just praised God and you know like
I said we're not here to bash anybody we
just want to create an awareness people
need to know people don't need to be
ignorant I was ignorant one time of this
um I don't know if you were raised in
this Faith tradition but I wasn't and it
was this message that really carried me
over when I found okay the Sabbath was
changed but when I found that the mark
of the beast would be legisla Sunday
worship I knew right there I could not
go back to church on Sunday
and I obey the call come out of her my
people the beautiful thing about it is
is that I feel feel at peace doing this
because I know I'm doing the Lord's will
and you know the Bible says we have to
do unto others as we would have them to
do unto us if we was on the other side
not knowing the truth would you want
somebody to at least give you a bible
study on it exactly it's not an easy
thing to step into an arena and and and
especially if your life has been wrapped
around the church I mean think about how
big of a of a thing that is in your
world and your your your your church
life is is a big part of who we are yes
and so I can imagine this being a stark
you know just like you know what are you
saying or whatever but just if you just
start out with one simple prayer Lord is
there truth in this if there is then
either show me or Lead Me and every
single time I've seen somebody do that
it's amazing how they get led to the
truth I
mean I God will not ignore you if you
pray that prayer he will not cuz I
remember when I was 17 I prayed the
prayer I said Lord show me what the
devil's going to do to deceive the world
and God had already set it up I had a
friend of mine at the SDA Church um my
best friend throughout High School all
of a sudden one day right after
graduation he sat down and shared with
me the message that I'm hearing telling
you now and led me gave me some
information and I read my way into the
truth but here's the powerful part 5
years before a canvas came to my
mother's house my mother's resting in
Jesus Jesus um and sold her one of the
books was Bible readings for the home
and I read my way into this truth and I
read my way into it God so what happens
is is that God has a thousand ways to
reach people um this some sometimes
direct sometimes through a process but
what happens is God knows how to bring
his people into the truth and here's the
beautiful thing about it you know I was
a big cartoon lover when I was younger
and one of the things I used to realize
is that the E the villain may seem to be
winning but in the end good always
overcomes evil and my last slide I love
this as you look on the screen no matter
what comes against us in these last days
with this crisis understand that Jesus
is going to win amen and the Bible says
in Revelation 15 that there would be
those who will stand on the sea of glass
having gotten the victory over the Beast
and over his image and over his Mark and
over the number of his name and how can
they have Victory unless they know what
it is that's right amen so if you want
to know what this is can they reach out
to you how can they get a yes let's go
to the screen right here we're working
with Billboards um billboard companies
to help get this billboard um up and we
have two websites project l.org project
lin.com and um there's other things here
if a person wants to donate towards
those projects um our phone numbers are
on the websites and as you see right
here this is what we're doing and we're
seeking to get the truth out and I want
to just show you one more billboard that
one of our uh viewers and who I work
with in New York we was able to get this
in New York City Hallelujah cost a lot
of money but we got it we got one about
the Sabbath and I think it's good to to
uh look at this God blessed the seventh
day and Sanctified it Genesis 2:3 Jesus
is the lord of the Sabbath Matthew 12:8
and there remaineth therefore a rest to
the people of God and that rest is in
Jesus the Sabbath is a symbol of
our salvific rest in him through his
righteousness by faith and Jesus offers
that rest to us and God says every
seventh day every Saturday come for that
24 hours as a symbol of how we're to
live every week resting from our works
to rest in his love amen if you have
questions I know Dr o here is very
passionate about this subject so please
feel free to reach out to us feel free
to reach out to him um we're passionate
about sharing information too and um of
course we're going to ask you know be
respectful we're hope we hope that we
were were being respectful in in talking
about this even if we don't see eye to
eye as maybe some of you guys but uh um
just you know humbly and prayerfully
just ask God to show you light in this
if there's some sort of light here like
you know let let that penetrate through
and um God will not ignore you and so we
thank you for stopping by and watching
this this uh Channel thank you for
subscribing to our Channel and sharing
our content it really helps um that's a
simple way for that you can enter into
Ministry work with us just like it share
it subscribe to us and um of course
check out latter rain Ministries and uh
the link is in the description below but
uh well thank you for stopping by we'll
see you guys next
week if you're looking for good
wholesome educational content for your
children subscribe to our new channel
little like
kids
[Music]
oh